los soldados ucranianos regresan al
escenario de una batalla que ganaron
ahora estamos en un antiguo puesto de
control ruso que fue destruido el 28 de
marzo
[Música]
entre los restos hay pruebas de saqueos
Mira incluso hay un baño aquí hay ropa
de mujer
un bolso de mujer una silla
en la distancia se escuchan las bombas
otro soldado llega para decir que
debemos tener cuidado el ejército
ucraniano expulsó a las fuerzas rusas De
esta zona en marzo pero intentarán
volver estos hombres de la zona dicen
que están cortando madera para las
trincheras ucranianas los soldados están
reforzando sus defensas ante el temor de
que se intensifiquen los ataques rusos
nada cuchicato los rusos necesitan al
menos un tipo de Victoria antes del 9 de
mayo porque Putin Bueno es un fanático
de esa fecha simbólicas pero no lo vamos
a permitir
estos hombres han estado ayudando al
ejército desde el principio de hecho
construyeron el puesto de control que
vimos antes que era ucraniano antes de
ser tomado por las fuerzas rusas unos 40
de nosotros construimos esto algo está
volando por allí
seguimos los soldados ucranianos estiman
que entre el 80 y el 90% de la población
Ha oído de estos pueblos
Ahora somos desplazados internos en el
oeste de Ucrania ahora Estamos
comprobando si aseguro volver
Hola
puedo abrazarte Gracias por estar aquí
protegiéndonos todo estará bien los
soldados dicen que tienen buenas
relaciones con la mayoría de los
aldeanos aunque no con todos esta
familia está claramente dispuesta a
ayudar el camino a través de esta vía es
más corto pero hay combates allí van a
disparar son cohetes grada sabes hace un
par de días escuchamos un fuerte sonido
Ah pero está en marcha lo que nunca
habíamos oído antes unas armas tan
poderosas Supongo que debió ser Europa
quien no las dio
en todo Ucrania la gente Ha oído hablar
de los suministros de armas occidentales
y cuenta con eso para seguir frenando a
los rusos